albert breer um
sports illustrated back here on the rich
eisen show how are you albert breer
yeah there's a lot of bad math out there
for you guys i mean like i was i think
three or four months three or four weeks
old for the miracle on ice so that one's
a natural for me and then
um i i have played that game i think it
was brockman that you were saying like
where you play the
this movie is this old yes yeah now go
backwards
and then that movie was that old back
then you know like and that's a really
dangerous game to play that'll make you
feel ancient i know i can't believe i
can't believe old school is 19. you're
19 years old i saw that in the
commercial break i'm like i cannot
believe old school is almost a 20 year
old movie it's just because i mean like
and i i actually like you know what i
was immediately thinking was
now am i older than the than the guys in
old school i think i am right like
because i think those guys were supposed
to be in their 30s right is that right
oh yeah we're all older than them now
yeah yeah i mean like so yeah it's
pretty depressing
okay albert let's jump into this with
both feet what is going on with the
combine right now because that's
supposed that's going down i'm i'm i'm
at the combine a week from tomorrow
getting ready to call that thing on nfl
network am i going to have 180 fewer
people to uh to discuss on nfl network
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
what happens rich because i i think what
the
there are a couple things that the
players are taking issue with here and
to be honest like i i've talked to some
teams too that that aren't happy about
it um and and really like what a lot of
this is about is notice you know like
that the players are finding out about
this a week ahead of time um you know
they're really upset about it like and
the agents are upset about it and so
the biggest issue really
is that you know for two three months
every one of these prospects the top
guys the guys who are invited to
indianapolis have these teams of people
around them right like so you have your
nutritionist you have your strength
coach you have your speed coach you have
all these different guys and the big
agencies bring those guys to
indianapolis so
they can continue to work with those
guys um while they're going through the
combine and you and i have seen this for
years i mean like you know in the
convention center you'll see
you know a guy late at night working on
his starts with his speed coach in the
hallways of the convention center
getting ready to run the 40 the next day
you know that's a common sight and so
like you know basically what the what
the bubble is going to do to these kids
is it's going to remove them from that
environment they've been in the last two
or three months by taking all these
specialists that they've hired away from
them
and i think that that's a huge problem
the nutrition part of it's a huge
problem
um you know and i i just think like a
lot of the the agents and the players
themselves feel like they're not being
in a position being put in a position
to perform at the highest level and
they're being put in this position with
almost no notice
and so i think that's why it's going the
way it's going um and you have a a a
handful of power broker agents that
represent you know a relatively large
percentage of the players threatening to
pull their guys out and i think the
question is going to become i mean like
look like you're aiden hutchinson's your
evan neils your cave on thibodeau's
those guys can probably just
unilaterally decide i'm not going and it
probably won't affect them much
you know but the guys who are put in the
real difficult position i'd say are like
the second third fourth round picks who
have really have something to lose or
gain
um and that's where i think these kids
are in a really really difficult
position and it'll be interesting to see
what the league does
to to to work through this
but i will say this you know a lot more
than one teams pointed out to me the
hypocrisy and the nfl lifting so many
restrictions so you get the super bowl
played get doubling back here and
putting a lot of those restrictions on
kids that really don't have any power to
fight it outside of this potential
boycott you know the interesting thing
is this is um part and parcel of the
combine becoming a
bigger televised event
is that
now there's more and more people who are
who are in the world of getting
players and prospects ready for the
combine
and um and it's a cottage industry now
yeah right and so players and agents are
now used to having a certain way to
prepare for it
and
um if that's being denied these players
then maybe they'll just wait for their
pro days
and
not go to the combine or just only do
the the medical part of it which i think
they're having a problem with
as well walk me through that do all 32
teams have their specific team doc so so
literally a prospect goes through 32
medical evaluations at the combine that
still happens
it doesn't quite happen that way but
there are i mean they do get they do
and i
i've written about this before and i
just i'm drawing a blank on the exact
but you know
it works in pools and everybody's got a
chance but team doctors have a chance to
talk to the kids and so like some of it
is definitely pooled they're not going
through 32 physicals um but you know
like they'll get in the room and
there'll be i i think the number is
something like six or seven team doctors
there that are sort of working as like a
like almost like pool reporters right on
what's happening and then that
information shared so yeah the 30 i mean
that's and i think you and i both know
this rachel that's the most important
part to the teams right like is the
medical information and that was the
biggest thing last year was making sure
there was access to the medical
information um you know there's stuff
that that that we all hype up you know
us that you know sports illustrated you
guys certainly at the nfl network the 40
the bench i mean that's sort of down the
list
for the teams what the teams really want
is the medical information and then the
interviews you know um and
so if you know like players aren't going
to go through some of that that's a real
problem for for each of the teams
you know and then
you know you'd be talking about getting
into the spring when you have an
opportunity to bring in guys for visits
and now all of a sudden you know like
the
the the the individual visits would
become very very important teams that
have to be i mean real calculating about
who they bring into their building to
to do those visits because you know
those visits are where you can get the
individual physicals with the individual
players albert breer the mmq be here on
the rich eisen show um and the new
league everything is so condensed now
because that extra week i'm beginning to
feel it for the first time normally it's
a bit of a while between uh the end of
the super bowl and the combine and then
um and then the combine to the new
league year but now we're we're on and
cracking and i know that there's there's
no you know everyone feels it's the
downtime or a down period but this is
when rogers is going to supposedly start
making a decision this is where we
will maybe hear more about what's going
on with kyla murray let's let's take
both of those right now since those are
the linchpins in a way
of the just how crazy this quarterback
carousel might spin over the next month
oh yeah i mean the key the key day
really is march 16th which is the start
of the league year start a free agency
and that's when
um you know team's plans start to
crystallize and so like that's the i
mean that's a really important
checkpoint
that said i think we we both know that
there can be a domino effect you know
and one quarterback comes off the market
and then you know
like that could lead to another team
saying okay like well now we got to make
our move for our
last year you know matthew stafford that
deal wasn't executed until the middle of
march the beginning of the league year
but it was agreed to before the super
bowl and the carson wentz deal i believe
was already done at this juncture on the
calendar last year as well and so you
know it's going to sort of be where's
the first domino
and it just feels to me like roger's
going to be the first domino now here's
how you want to look at this
yeah i really feel like the personal
part of the relationship between
rogers and the packers has been taken
care of and is in a much better place
than it was last year you know he
publicly thanked mark murphy and brian
guticus the two guys he had the biggest
problems with last year in his mvp
speech and i know the packers feel like
the personal issue that rogers had with
them
is
is is if not gone in a much better place
than it was last year and i think you
know if you look the way it went last
year i mean there was a period i mean i
hate to use the kids term ghosted but
there was a period of a month or two
there where the packers literally
couldn't get a hold of aaron rodgers so
they're not there anymore i think now
what it's going to come down to with
rogers is the professional part of it
can they convince aaron rodgers that
they'll be able to manage their cap
issue they're about 40 million dollars
over project to be that far over
um and put the same sort of team around
them they've put around them over matlab
floors first three years
so that i think they've eliminated the
personal issue and now it's going to
come down to whether or not aaron
rodgers thinks the best thing for him
professionally is to be in green bay so
then before before before we jump to
kyler i mean so the jordan love we've
got to get him in there because we
drafted him and we're gonna it's it the
clock is ticking and we absolutely need
to know who we have in him that's done
two back back-to-back mvps of have
effectively neutralized the drafting of
jordan love yeah you believe yeah i i i
think so i mean i i think the the way
you want to look at it similar to brady
and garoppolo in new england you know
where where brady just basically kept
beating garoppolo out you know and and
and look like i think that was the first
quarterback bill took in new england
where the intention was this is going to
be brady's successor and brady was just
so good over the period of time they had
garoppolo on a rookie contract that the
timing didn't work and so they wind up
trading garoppolo to san francisco it
wasn't that they didn't like jimmy they
thought jimmy could be their starting
quarterback
it was just that the timing didn't work
because brady was able to sustain such
success i think the same sort of thing
is playing out now in green bay so
yeah i mean my guess would be
i mean
i think they'd be i think if they can
find a way to keep rogers based on the
you know state of the roster how many
guys they have in the prime of their
careers
like yeah i think they'd be all ears if
teams started to call and made offers on
jordan love i think that's the point
they're probably at now wow okay yeah
let's move on to kyler murray what but
again like i want to emphasize when i
say that like that contingent on rogers
of course no i know that it takes two to
tango but the fact was it that there was
no tango as you pointed out there was no
dance there was no nothing because there
was
jordan love there and the fact that that
uh that's no longer the come heck hecker
high water uh approach by the the
packers when it comes to rogers that
it's okay
i guess you proved us wrong with the
back-to-back mvps we're gonna we're
gonna stick with the program if you're
willing to stick with it then that's a
change that's a definite shift and there
are some moving parts there too i mean i
think that that would be contingent on
him signing an extension you know but if
they sign him to say a you know two
two-year hundred million dollar
extension let's just throw that out
there and it's fully guaranteed um and
that helps them manage their cap issue
well then like then how does the timing
work out what you're in love you know
and that then you're basically saying
george love's never going to start
starting quarterback because his rookie
deal is going to be up before rogers is
out of his guaranteed money albert brie
here on the rich eisen show let's move
on to murray what what what's what the
hell man i mean what's happening i guess
it's quiet now but quiet always means
something's up
that always means something's up
yeah and i think it's um sort of i you
know where where you are with these
young quarterbacks and you know when
they're on their rookie deals and you
know really you know the first kind of
critical point is after year three
that's when they're eligible for a new
deal that's when you know the team has
to make a decision on the fifth year
option
which is obviously a big deal now
because those are fully guaranteed now
they weren't the old cba
um and so you know i think for the
cardinals
there was some stuff from a leadership
standpoint that left them wanting you
know and so i don't know if kyler
actually went to the
cardinals looking for an extension
um you know but i i do think that
there's you know like a leadership
question there and and being the guy for
them where you know you can ask that
question and say is
is he the guy that we're willing to pay
45 or 50 million dollars a year for and
i don't know they have that that
question answered yet maybe they want to
see a little bit more over a fourth year
and if that's your answer there well
then to me
i i think it sort of brings up the i
mean it certainly it to me would bring
up the question
of
you know how is the player going to
accept how's the player going to take
that and if you're kyler murray you
might not take that very well so i think
that's sort of where they are
and um and yeah i mean i don't know how
you work that out you know like a lot of
times things get really awkward in year
four we saw with cleveland and baker
mayfield right like cleveland didn't
want to commit to baker yet and things
definitely got pretty awkward in his
fourth year there um you know i think if
they're going to go forward with kyle
and i don't have any indication that
they aren't at this point i think it
could be a pretty awkward thing because
you know this is again sort of the point
where
um you know all players the quarterbacks
in particular are looking for their
their big payday and and to be fair to
kyler the history shows i mean you look
at goffin once in the 16 class watson in
the homes in the 17 class allen and the
18 class
the guys that teams are really sure
about those guys get extended after year
three albert breer here on the rich
eisen show
earlier
on monday kevin colbert the outgoing
general manager
of the pittsburgh steelers talked to the
media he was asked what the um the
signing of brian flores to be uh the
defensive assistant
as well as
the uh what is it the defensive
assistant coach and then there's
linebackers coach asked what does that
the uh the hiring mean he said it means
we hired an uh an excellent coach
so i'll ask you what it means
albert i i think it's i think it's a
really good sign that mike tomlin's
looking to inject new ideas into his
building um and again like hiring a
really good coach you know and i think
one of the things that flow will bring
is a different set of eyes to
the operation um and i think terrell
austin the new
defensive coordinator does that too with
his baltimore roots um but what brian
flores will do is sort of i think bring
the idea that maybe
they don't have to be the way they've
always been pittsburgh's been
defensively always the sort of team
that um will try to dictate terms to an
offense whereas you know where flores is
coming from the new england background
is you change from week to week based on
what you're off your your opponent does
well and what your opponent's presenting
you and so i think you know in that way
um brian four is going to be able to
bring a fresh set of ideas a fresh set
of eyes to everything pittsburgh does i
think the steelers will benefit from
that the other part of it that i really
like is that just the talent development
um aspect of it he was so good in new
england as far as developing talent both
young and old was the linebackers coach
i think kyle van noy and dante hightower
were at their best when he was a
safeties coach he helped transition
devin mccourty from a corner to safety
in a position that he wound up being all
pro at resurrected patrick chung's
career developed around harman so that's
the other part of it it's going to be
interesting to see what this means for
younger players or even veteran players
you know like guys like tj watt i think
will benefit from it but then you're
younger guys like you're devin bush and
you're making fitzpatrick i i think stan
to to really benefit from it as well and
then the lawsuit aspect of it what about
that well the lawsuit aspect of it i
don't think
i know this brian flores is a pretty
principled guy
and my guess is that any sort of
discussion of the lawsuit was broached
by mike tomlin before this
and i think you know
i can't imagine this is going to affect
brian flores stance on that because he
is a principled guy and i mean look rich
here's the thing too if there's one
ownership family that's going to support
him you know and this sort of thing who
is it
the rooney family right
so i don't think that that should be
lost on anybody either
well i mean uh if there's an opportunity
to put a gopro uh on art rooney
walking into the owner's meeting when
that happens in march and seeing stephen
ross i would pay for that i'd pay for
that right now
you know i mean and and seriously like
okay so you hire the guy that accuses me
of tanking
you know or giving him uh six figures to
tank uh i i i you know i i wonder how
that's gonna sit you know you know
here's what's interesting about it
though rich is like i don't know if you
noticed during the change of tone in the
press conference um from from roger last
week
i i don't i don't think i've been
covering the league 17 years i can't
remember him ever openly talking about
ousting an owner let alone like going
into the process of it you know what i
mean
and you know whether you know that that
affects schneider or ross or whoever
else
um
i definitely took note of the fact that
that roger was openly talking about what
it would take to take a team away from
an owner because i don't think that's
something he would have done five or ten
years ago
and and i think that tells you a little
something about where things are in the
ranks of owners now where maybe there
are some owners that aren't happy with
the way other owners are operating
and you know maybe roger feels like
if it does come to the point where he
does have to take out an owner whether
again it's a snyder or ross or whoever
like maybe he actually has the support
to do something like that that's just my
read on it like again like reading the
tea leaves and having done this as long
as i have i don't know anything concrete
on it like that he would have that
support but it just sort of feels that
way based on the way he talked last week
albert thanks for the time sounds like
you got your hands full too yeah good
morning cool vacation week so uh we're
going to the bruins game now but uh and
we've all been caught in traffic so the
timing didn't work out great but but but
we made it work i hope i was okay you
were great you were great you lit the
lamp like i hope the bruins will for you
and your family there you go thank you
so much appreciate it albert you're the
best and i didn't even bring up john
howard how about that well you're around
kids don't do that
don't throw hands when you're around
children okay no no we're gonna keep our
hands to ourselves no i saw that you
said woody hayes is off the hook as if
that's in any way shape or form in the
same area code you know what's funny
about that is how many people took that
seriously that tweet was you know me i
was just messing around you put it out
and you put it out there
i put it out there
i was obviously joking i mean this is
something that happened in the 70s and
my god the amount of people that thought
i was serious about that it's
mind-blowing albert there's no joking on
twitter you you're aware no no don't
don't don't don't apply twitter to
albert like that albert you have a
reputation of being a troll you know
that you know that
but at least but at least but at least
recognize that i'm trolling
like some people were acting like i was
dead serious you knew what troll fox
that was trolling you need a troll font
there needs to be a troll font it could
be like comic sans right yes exactly
speaking of which we'll talk about
cleveland in the all-star game very
shortly thank you for the call albert
thank you sir all right thanks richard
that's albert heading to the bruins game
with his kids
there's fighting in hockey games so
maybe he was just oh boy getting ready
oh my gosh michigan's a boxing school
now says mike deltufa well done at
hockey school
who did you see that on twitter and you
stole it from
i made that up on my own okay
[Music]
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here